cours de français dans une classe
d'immigrants de québec
les adolescents et jeunes adultes qui
viennent du congo de la côte d'ivoire du
népal entre autres je commence à m très
bien je commence à m'entendre avec
d'autres personnes que que les personnes
du bord on dit de leur intégration va au
delà des cours il faut aussi du sport
avec d'autres immigrants et des
québécois l'organisme qui les
accompagnent veut permettre de faire
vivre à ces jeunes une expérience qui
les sort de leur quotidien
un groupe de quinze migrants donc va se
rendre du vieux port de montréal à
québec à vélo
je suis content parce que et c'est un
déficit en plus sur mon premier hiver
enfin des sports avec les jamais les
jeunes vont pédaler cinq heures par jour
jusqu'à leur arrivée à québec judy ils
vont aussi participer à des conférences
sur l'intégration
on veut aller laisser un message
d'espoir dans les écoles on veut au sel
et parle aux jeunes de l'importance de
bien accueil des nouveaux arrivants
ça m'a jamais fait m'intégrer bien d'un
culte et quelques pas avec le feu en
2016 le québec a accueilli dix mille
réfugiés la plupart pour un foyer à
montréal ou québec on voit ça comme un
peu le parcours du combattant d'une
façon symbolique parce que quand ils
migrent là à québec
bête de nombreuses embûches on était
dans une misérable des familles
misérables et maintenant ici on manque
rien ils avaient la guerre tout ça
c'était vraiment
le moment que je voulais depuis jamais
vu ça il n'est pas venu plus jamais ça
fait le plein accord de la magie donc
l'élever tous choisi la bonne nouvelle
pour ces cyclistes cette activité est
l'occasion d'un nouveau départ
et si marc laménie radio canada montréal